DAVID HANSON AND A LOT MORE, BUT
FIRST ONCE AGAIN, THIS WAS ALL
SIZZLE NO STEAK AT THE D&C, SO
THEY TROTTED OUT THE PARTIES
LAST GLOBAL SUPERSTAR, BARACK
OBAMA, BUT THAT JUST ENDED UP
REINFORCING WHAT THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY ALREADY KNOWS.
JOE BIDEN IS NO BARACK OBAMA.
NOW OBAMA’S ALMOST 60, BUT HE
STILL HAS A SWAGGER AND YOU CAN
SEE IT ONE OF THE MOST TALENTED
POLITICIANS IN THE LAST 50 YEARS
.
>> I UNDERSTAND WHY A LOT OF
AMERICANS ARE DOWN ON GOVERNMENT
.
I UNDERSTAND WHY A WHITE FACTORY
MERKER WHO SEEN HIS WAGES CUT OR
HIS JOB SHIPPED OVERSEAS MIGHT
FEEL LIKE THE GOVERNMENT NO
LONGER LOOKS OUT FOR HIM.
AND WHY A BLACK MOM MIGHT FEEL
LIKE IT NEVER LOOKED OUT FOR HER
AT ALL.
>> OF COURSE THEY TRIED THIS
ALMOST THE SAME LINES IN 2016
WITH HILLARY CLINTON AND THEY
FAILED MISERABLY.
BUT DEMOCRATS THINK JOE ISN’T A
BETTER PLACE THAN HILLARY WAS
BECAUSE JOE HAS TWO RUNNING
MATES KAMALA AND COVID.
BUT TO PROMS WITH ATCO MUST BE
ONE IS TOO RADICAL FOR MOST
SWING VOTERS, YOU HEAR HER TALK
ABOUT STRUCTURAL RACISM TONIGHT
AND COVID IS BEGINNING TO FATE
AND THE RED STATES WHERE PEOPLE
ARE GOING BACK TO WORK, GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL AND PLAYING
FOOTBALL.
BACK TO OBAMA, THEIR STAR
TONIGHT.
IF YOU THINK YOU’RE GETTING IN
OBAMA THIRD TERM WITH BIDEN,
IT’S IMPORTANT TO TAKE A REALITY
CHECK.
AND LOOK AT WHAT HE ACCOMPLISHED
READ HIS TRADE POLICY ENCOURAGE
MORE OUTSOURCING OF AMERICAN
JOBS TWO FOREIGN KURDS COUNTRIES
.
EVEN HILLARY CLINTON WALKED AWAY
FROM IT WHEN SHE CAMPAIGNED, AND
BIDEN, DISINGENUOUSLY OF COURSE
CLAIMS HE WOULD CHANGE IT.
OBAMA’S HEALTHCARE PLAN WAS SO
UNPOPULAR IT LED TO HIS PARTY
LOSING ITS HOUSE MAJORITY IN
2010.
OBAMA’S DOJ RAN ROUGHSHOD OVER
RELIGIOUS LIBERTY AND WAS
SMACKED DOWN BY THE SUPREME
COURT FOR DOING IT TO THE LITTLE
SISTERS OF THE BOARD.
OBAMA’S IMMIGRATION AND BORDER
POLICY MADE IT EASIER FOR
ILLEGAL ALIENS TO COME HERE AND
GET BENEFITS FROM SCHOOLING TO
FOOD STAMPS, THIS KEPT WAGES
DOWN FOR WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS
AS WELL.
OBAMA’S FOREIGN-POLICY BLUNDERS
LED TO THE RISE OF ISIS AND A
CHINA UNCHECKED AND UNCHALLENGED
.
AND THEN CAME 2016.
>> THE REASON I’M HERE IS
BECAUSE OF PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
JOE BIDEN, BECAUSE IF THEY DID A
GOOD JOB, I WOULDN’T BE HERE.
I ENJOYED MY PREVIOUS LIFE VERY
MUCH, BUT THEY DID SUCH A BAD
JOB I STAND BEFORE YOU AS
PRESIDENT.
>> HE IS 100 PERCENT RIGHT.
WE ALREADY HAD EIGHT YEARS OF
OBAMA AND THE END WAS IN AMERICA
FIRST TRUMP PRESIDENCY, SO WITH
THE PIXIE DUST HE WAS PRICKLING
TONIGHT WAS MORE LIKE SAND IN
YOUR EYE.
>> I’M IN PHILADELPHIA WERE OUR
CONSTITUTION WAS DRAFTED AND
SIGNED.
IT WASN’T A PERFECT DOCUMENT,
BUT EMBEDDED IN THIS DOCUMENT
WAS A NORTHSTAR THAT WOULD GUIDE
FUTURE GENERATIONS.
A SYSTEM OF REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT, A DEMOCRACY, TO
WHICH WE COULD BETTER REALIZE
OUR HIGHEST IDEALS.
>> IGNORE THAT HISTORIC SETTING,
IT WAS BEAUTIFULLY LIT AND
EVERYTHING, THE REFERENCES TO
THE FOUNDERS ARE CUTE, BUT WE
KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON.
REMEMBER WHAT HIS MORALIST RABID
FOLLOWERS WERE DOING TO OUR
HISTORY, OUR HISTORICAL MARKERS,
FOR THE PAST FEW MONTHS OR SO.
>> MOUNT RUSHMORE IS NATIONAL
SYMBOL OF WHITE SUPREMACY.
>> QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN RAISED
ABOUT THOMAS JEFFERSON IN
PARTICULAR, BUT ALSO ABOUT
GEORGE, WASHINGTON,.
>> I DON’T CARE THAT MUCH ABOUT
STATUES.
>> PEOPLE ARE MAKING A STATEMENT
.
ABOUT EQUALITY, I THINK IT’S A
HEALTHY EXPRESSION.
>> IT’S A HEALTHY EXPRESSION.
WENT ON THEY TARRIED TO TAKE
DOWN THAT MUSEUM TOO?
WE SAW TONIGHT THE CHOICE IS
CLEAR, THE PANELISTS WILL GET
INTO ALL OF THIS BUT IF THE
DEMOCRATS WIN, THE DONORS ARE
GETTING TO GET THERE CHEAPER
FOREIGN LABOR AGAIN AND THE
CHANCE TO SHIP MORE JOBS
OVERSEAS AGAIN.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WIN, THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE WARRIORS ARE GOING TO
GET TO PROGRAM THE SCHOOLS, PACK
THE COURTS, AND RE- WEAPON EYES
THEY JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
A THIRD FAR MORE RADICAL OBAMA
THIRD TERM, BUT WITHOUT OBAMA
AND ALL HIS STAR POWER AND